foreign
Ohio and talk to Andrew what's up Andrew
hey John how you doing partying man
that's not true that's not true I'm at
work what are you doing
I'm finishing up some notes for my work
excellent but uh I I appreciate you
taking my call man I really appreciate
your wisdom and your honesty and I've
really enjoyed your show so thanks for
having me on you got it what's happening
well how can I help
so um find myself in a pretty
complicated situation in my marriage
been married almost four years now
um
and my wife has
um struggled with a lot of addiction and
there has been a pretty significant
amount of
um manipulation and deception that's
taken place over the last uh really the
entire course of our marriage what's her
uh what's her addiction of choice
yeah it's uh so she struggles with an
eating disorder
um so you know I guess maybe not your
traditional like drug or alcohol
addiction
um but to the point where uh you know
she's she's chosen to
um
manipulate
um myself and just situations and
deceives needs in order for it to to
manifest and to
um take on you know binge Purge
behaviors and restrictive behaviors and
things so
she's been in and out of inpatient
Outpatient Therapy we've done counseling
marriage counseling and unfortunately
it's just the patterns have continued to
take place
um so my question to you is
um
you know about three or four months ago
just after kind of realizing things were
still as as bad as they always have been
um I started really struggling myself
with just panic attacks and
pretty severe depression anxiety just
feeling so trapped by the situation
to the point where you know it made some
boundaries that were crossed and I had
her move back in with her parents
and so we're at a point now where what
were those boundaries were those
boundaries
um so unfortunately one of the only
objective measures for for growth and
for
um
for both of us don't you know really
have a full picture of where she's at is
weight
um and just kind of measures of honesty
of checking in each day making sure that
everything she's saying and doing is
consistent with you know what we're
seeing as far as like um
our weight
and um just was continuing to lose
weight and kind of stay like underweight
and um
so despite you know telling me
everything was going fine and she was
doing all the right things
was still just kind of seeing that
objective measurement
um
hopefully that makes sense yeah
yeah so
so you kicked her out unfortunately she
went to live with her parents
yep she's with her parents now so if
she's been there for the last
two months and there's just
you know she's very frustrated and angry
with me because
she wants me to move toward her and and
build back Trust
but at this point I mean trust is not
only damaged it's gone you know it's out
the window and um
so I'm just struggling to survive myself
at this point you know I'm I'm actually
an ER Doc and I'm struggling even at
work sometimes to stay focused just
because the
it's just a constant thing on my mind
you know and um so I'm trying to figure
out how can I
guard my own hearts and my own mental
health
um
you know while the trauma is still kind
of continuing to happen even though
she's
telling me that it's not or she's
telling me that she's different even
though I'm still seeing objective
behaviors taking place that make me
pretty uh assured that they are still
happening so you're a medical doctor
I am yeah okay I can I can have a little
bit different conversation with you than
I I might with just like a
a dad is a roof a husband is a roofer or
something sure
for some reason you have you are
taking her actions
let me say it this way this isn't you're
holding her accountable for the results
of an illness
and you're making them very behavioral
in a way and then you're taking
you're taking her behavior personally
and so the best way I could I could
suggest this is
maybe analogy and this may not work
perfectly but
um
I have a seven-year-old little girl and
she has
um I she's had some respiratory
challenges some restricted breathing
recently and for a couple of nights in a
row
she came into a me and my wife's room at
3am
sick exhausted coughing from her what
felt like from her guts and
um unable to breathe and we're having to
run through breathing treatments and
stuff which is not normal for her
right
but she continued to come
to the one safe place
and what I didn't do was get really
pissed at her
for coughing
because that's a function of
her challenges with her lungs
and so you've got a wife with a
significant mental health disorder
and this the seeds of this are planted
long before y'all got together
right and you have two people who are
all about control
and you're exerting it in different ways
you have a very intellectual control
which is a very emotional control
and she's gonna pull you using that and
you're gonna try to pull her back using
intellect
and so you get in this strange dance
but you're getting really pissed that
she's coughing
the challenge with and you know this
from your training the challenge with
distorted eating
is using relationship as a as a weapon
just throws gasoline on that fire
yeah exactly you know what I mean
like for punishment for not for her
punishment for coughing was she doesn't
get to see you anymore or live in her
own home that was her punishment
there was a line that her coughing
crossed and you said you're out of my
life until you fix coughing
when they're really the only way to fix
coughing is relational connection and
then the healing can actually start
so I guess more so
as I told her over the years you know I
said I'm I'm not I'll never be upset
with you for struggling with mental
illness I said the only thing I I ever
want from you is your honesty yeah but
that is that's a function of it
sure
and I guess what I struggle is is not
having the foundation of of trust in our
marriage leaks over into to every aspect
of of the marriage because for me it's
like how can I trust you with with
anything when when I can't trust you
with just like these these daily
questions and and things you know
and
I just I worry you know like about a
future like when we have
kids or or like really difficult life
challenges you know not being able to
to trust her I just yeah so let's flip
this around
sure
I'm trying I really want to talk nerd
with you like it makes my heart feel
good that I'm talking like I get to talk
to a uh I mean you're way smarter than
me I'm a nerd too man well but I want to
make sure people can follow us
um
uh
um let me say it like this it sounds
like you are treating her as a patient
and the difference is you get to weigh
her in and check her blood and her blood
pressure
every minute of every day
and so my question for you is what if
you stopped putting her in a position
when you know that shame
is one of the core DNA functions of
disordered eating
sure not putting her in a position to
have to lie it's the same thing I tell
parents if you know your kid took the
cookie you know it you see chocolate on
their face
start there don't say did you take that
cookie and then they're like no Mom and
then get pissed at him for lying you
just set up you just set that whole
thing up
just sit down and go hey you have
chocolate on your face you took one
cookies I told you not to and we're
gonna have to I'm gonna have to hold you
accountable for this action don't add
something to it so is there a way that
she becomes your wife and not your
patient
um because you're creating a world that
somebody with her particular mental
health disorder and if you've listened
to this show you know it's rare that I
say that you I'm almost always saying
it's a context not an excuse right just
because you have anxiety and you may
even be you may have a you know a GED
just a diagnostic whatever you still got
to tell the truth right
this one this is the core function of
this is hiding and shame it's part of
the loop man and so what if instead of
saying did you eat today did you purge
today did you do this today
you just held her hand
and said I'm so happy to see you
how can I love you today
if you tried that for 30 days I might be
out to lunch man but I almost am willing
to bet that her
parasympathetic system could finally
kick in she could breathe
yeah
but I do got to tell you I mean you know
it's been almost four years now we've
been married and I knew about this you
know pretty soon after we got married
because she was just obviously losing
weight didn't have a period for a year
and a half I mean got to the point where
she was down to 80 pounds and was Dane
it was dangerous absolutely dangerous
absolutely
and throughout that whole time you know
I had a lot of people in my life saying
like hey man this is this is bad like I
think you should get out
and you know I defended her tooth and
nail and just said this is my wife this
is our lot and that was you know I mean
I'm not just trying to blow smoke
here you know I mean that was my
Approach was no matter what like there's
going to be Grace there's going to be
love like I'm going to encourage her
and I think but are you but are you
showing Grace and love the way that you
know how or the way she needs it
well I guess that's a good question I
mean the whole the whole weighing thing
didn't happen until
she came back from treatment because
that's kind of how they were and again I
know I'm not I'm not in that role of a
counselor or you know a dietitian but
like that's kind of how they were
continuing to monitor her her progress
and I I just I didn't know what to do I
mean I saw her continue to lose weight
I'm with you I I I'm terrified for you
you know this as well as I do for people
listening
um this is last I looked it was the
number one it's the most lethal mental
health disorder there is yeah yeah um
this is a scary scary thing and to see
someone you love wither away to 80 I
mean that's that is
that's all that's that's terrifying so
yeah I I I want you to hear me in no
shape form of fashion is this your fault
am I blaming you
Maybe here's an analogy that will work
my dad was a homicide detective he's a
trained
um question asker he also was the uh
hostage negotiator for the SWAT team so
if somebody had a bomb or somebody was
going to jump off a building they called
my dad in and he's got a very disarming
funny I learned every I mean I learned
the way I approached life from from him
okay
and they told him during training
you cannot bring this skill set to your
home because you'll melt your kids
and one of the most raw honest
conversations we ever had was several
years ago when he looked at me and said
I don't think I did a good job
and I remember
being a kid feeling like I was getting
interrogated
for did I finish raking the yard it was
an intensity to it and a directionist to
it you see what I'm saying it was the
professional skill set that he had
and he's just trying to get to the
bottom of it
he said man I I don't think I did a good
job of of not bringing that home
thank you kids we're the brunt of that
so what I'm suggesting to you is I don't
think she needs another physician at her
house she needs someone that just loves
and let me tell you this if you are done
in this marriage have the courage to be
done in this marriage
because you can get dangerously close to
wanting to be done with this and then
looking for every possible way to make
this the ending of this her fault
yeah if you leave that's a choice you
make I have the courage to stand up and
make that choice
yeah are you done
uh getting pretty close I think to be
honest kind of feeling feeling pretty um
just bent like I have nothing left do
you have somebody else
no no okay
yeah
um but I appreciate that and makes a lot
of sense John so what's what's your next
what's your next move
is she still down to 80 pounds
no she's she's not she's
she's closer to a healthy weight at this
point I mean has not has not progressed
um over the past year what would she
need to do
for you to
actually let me let me give you this
analogy if you've ever listened to show
you've heard me say this and I'm just
going to say it again for everybody yeah
the marriage you thought you would have
four or five years in
is not what has happened right
the woman you married in many ways is
different than the person you thought
you married and probably vice versa
yeah
the goal now isn't to try to get back
the goal now isn't to try to remember
when
when we were dating and I was in med
school and we were kind of crazy and I
was working these crazy hours and you'd
those days are over
the question you have to ask yourself is
are you willing
to work with her and is she willing to
work with you to rebuild something
completely new from this point forward
because that's really your only option
It's that or we both walk away
right
yeah yeah I certainly realize it's not
about trying to get back to what we
thought was because I mean in reality
that that never was you know yes and so
how long does she struggle with this
foreign well I think I think a lot
longer than I realized
um and it got really severe after we got
married
um but I think she had some Tendencies
of disordered eating even back in high
school
she had a good relationship with her dad
um I do it does she
oh does she she does she does yeah
um it's he's always kind of
been a
yeah I mean they've always been really
close I don't think he really opens up a
whole lot with her but do you supportive
with her dad no with her
I'm sorry do I have a good relationship
with her do you open up to her
oh yeah okay
yeah
I mean at this point uh you know the
last few times we've talked I've just
been a blubbering mess so there's not a
whole lot hidden at this point good
I mean I hate to tell you this but
that's that's the only the only the only
way this thing survives is if you are
all in
yeah and all in not trying to be the
reserved ER physician that says
you have some insert big fancy name but
it's the one that sits down and holds a
patient's hand and said I'm so sorry
that's the guy she needs
the husband that says
not the not the clinician that is like
well you're up 2.3 percent body weight
and you're
she needs the guy that says I miss my
wife
and that's not even going to guarantee
it because she may not quote unquote
miss her husband
yeah
I think the question moving forward is
what is it going to take what what what
standards if you will standards is a bad
word is a bad way to say that but
what would she have to do
what needs do you need Matt
how can she love you
and vice versa how can you love her
so maybe that's the the path if there is
one forward
if there's some sort of trial move back
in for 30 days
a every single day how can I love you
today
I'm not going to ask you any questions
I'm not going to put you on any I'm not
going to judge anything I'm not going to
I'm not going to investigate you I'm not
going to run blood panels on you you're
not my patient you're my wife
how can I love you today
and you get to say what you need to be
loved
you get to say that out loud too
and y'all get to work together
and man I'm sorry that the woman you
love is sick sick sick sick
that breaks my heart she's in scaryville
but if she's stable over a year maybe
maybe we're on the on the right path
because I've seen that healing too
thank you for loving her remember
she's the woman I love not my patient
she's the woman I committed everything
to
she's not a client
foreign